okay so let's paul op thea studay story
about
democratic fundraising for twenty
men
yesterday i told you bernie sanders
had
explosion spokesman for racing and
funny nineteen bernie racing for the
four half a million dollars
this was the large a single core door
for ni democratic and did  in the entire
traditional action cycle'
already once with cars from racing vegetable garden
bernie web
dieser very serious van racing numbers
and the numbers in paris army king the
establishment glasses they long with the
polling never seen of the last few weeks
and seat diastole bernie know  in the
democratic nomination what a great
idea of ​​issue
barry ze serious contender for the
démocratique nomination of dit menschen
yesterday de donald trumps van racing
stil greatly i see this yes or bernie
sanders ze let's talk about box numbers
despite bernie nice de the river after
half  million dollars race last quarter
downgrade even more download from great
for the six milli  on dollars in love
of score dare of the nineteen they
were sir de more than bernie get some
major adventure trump india media
well this is an influence r&c way
republic national comedy way that
windows in your ear for donald trump
trump well like a scribble of  save and
chu million dollars to those who cramps
ben racing harmony
keith well and spending wel martians
democrats for spending money day race
against each other big stern in the
primer 1 l
donald trump ellis for now he is now'
primary so the issue nelly comes  what is
donald trump
sirius of racing counters and winebar that
is has donald trump is mostly raising
money for people who voted for him in
anyway de fundraising may or may not a
les very much
belgium burgundy boat in november 2012
has bernie sanders images
coalition drop  growth people who never
bothered in 2016 in good people who were
too young to fall in 2016 hello be
voting in 2012 as
well people who voted for s  ummer i
els en 2016
de change en bernie is fundraising from
2016 to 20 my mind single thing that i
could enthusiasm from some of the same
people who the dutch word pearly
in 2016 power bi can sign for some of
my bernie sanders
so another matter  van destouches
that donald trump
races way more than any individual
democracy' children in favor of scooters
from jantine
at donald trump race 2 lesson of all
democracy' hendriks together pieces
bernie sanders rhetoric for million
and already with warn't hair oil raced
offspring sony  and the andrew and race the
bunch and pipo the great if you are all
together all of the democracy gallery
significant more than donald trump
it's not crazy to imagine the if the
democratic primary can this ship
mean down and eventually we have na
mini
they're  all of this money wilkins all the
detail de démocratique na mini
en je very well correction the amount of
money donald trump jesus this is as
speculative and sso reminder
i know  that for love you why do have
these were talking about this week with
this is the way de systemworks
guides shack rose of broken system zo
camping finance
nothing 3 fixed money and politics not
wie fix on this caused by the fact that
you after eight money in  order to have
successful camping
given day you were talking about his big
arena l'accident and man and ryan old
win this far travel money but is
this cutting system that we have
tension hit then people go
lets look at the other side with it is
possible
yes dan big van racing numbers in
de la squadra funny 19
jimmy de download from this point you
very well en twinny load now we will
look at the national bowling and access
height het atelier t was by persons
kramp could you for and by en
almost force of us by the views from versus
bernie also performs for and bernie swing
at eat and where encounter realize
mobility
who minecraft henk who god is who god is
in the mountains and special in ell with war
we the brown at the table i mobile and
even bigger
challenge since presidents off and benefit
for military conflict soow de justify the
roon relaxing donald trump is rising
love of money like
weekend your is fight for ever i
would you nothing
volunteer van bank video van show  them
from and i get people registry for
member
the effort that require checking for
long john west you can probably get some
people maybe even 15 people who have
read this blog where thinking about
dwelling
green profit m2 boat is a much more
efficient mien zwen in biology  and the
french argu with chrome best were many
cases
completely beyond reach that my sense of
oil not too expensive about the nexttime us and
the online supply
well who her phenotype it feels actresses
and since just write up is a few bits
with the fresh butter chomicha  penguin man
disappeared
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh that
of the die and CSI zinc white in 3 months
who wants basically no good name  and honor
gwine t be there is no very much time
lapse the election quick of understanding in
apeldoorn
this is the teeth current and and ajax
elephants this bean show is could
bring
some interesting joe biden released
after a single be interesting to produce
lily in en de  concerning the many and
our audience about some things de joe
biden and anyway reset we got a grab
ownership for you they almost produce
the friday bonus show my baby back with
a new show and we hosting the
bonus show on monday thanks again for
johnny  johnny johnny keep those who just
finntroll thing in above all i wanna see
more about of the this job my show
intro not one i would you wanna feel so
some people for a we serious yesterday
once a few hosting means my
show any more lamina you  is a
jogging suit at six or seven three emails
from peebles and davy doon t doon actually
quite hosting die this task because shall
not going to a time that was also
down i wanna hear from you wer  e you
why en tony tony tony show
coming up to show the boat show in
london